but he could be president from jail
theoretically right yeah and he's like
pardon himself and if he gets convicted
they can take his name off the ballot
and then a lot of people will just vote
R and they won't even think twice about
who's on the ballot or not so much
people write them in you know split the
vote yup and then you end up with
Newsome as president I think that's a
strong possibility have you guys heard
my theory I mentioned the past couple
days no what is it job uh Gavin Newsom
is campaigning with Joe Biden and Joe
Biden has like a heart attack or
something Gavin Newsom runs at full
speed on the stage rolls up his sleeves
and does CPR and Biden and that would be
fun screams for help and then what
happens Biden either is okay or
incapacitated Gavin Newsom then does
every press round where they're like
tell us what it was like when you ran
out to save the president's life how do
you get Gavin Newsom above Joe Biden in
the polls above Kamala Harris how do you
replace Biden with Gavin Newsom how do
you replace him without overstepping or
insulting Kamala Harris and and you know
the woke crowd Gavin Newsom saving the
life of Joe Biden